here are some happy vampire bats what's
causing all this giddiness a great big
fat meal has arrived you can practically
hear these bats going oh boy oh boy
better yet the victim is asleep this is
going to be like well taking blood from
a sleeping pig the bats have heat
sensors in their noses this thermal
process lets us see what the bat sees
the bat wants to feed where the pigs
skin glows white hot let the dining
commence like to wildcatters fighting
over a fresh oil strike these bats
battle over a particularly rich feeding
spot poor vampire bats one sleeping pig
why doesn't the pig wake up because the
bats teeth are razor sharp and cut
painlessly the bats can sip to their
heart's content with a pig none the
wiser the bat saliva actually prevents
the blood from clotting
as the bat sips the blood runs up a
groove on the underside of its tongue
Mother Nature thinks of everything these
vampire bats can feast for a full
half-hour drinking half their weight in
blood in a month of feedings five
vampire bats can guzzle almost a gallon
of pig's blood in this case it's the
bats making a pig of themselves not the
pig